j'ai souffert ne pas voir de ces
cultures pour madame en hausse et la
miss a été dur mais j'ai accepté parce
que c'est ce qu'elle voulait et je me
suis dit c'est beau c'est généreux et
derrière ils ont fait n'importe quoi
avec les corps de votre prochain
[Musique]
alors ma mère à mes soixante neuf ans
quand elle est décédée elle avait un
cancer incurable ans et quelques temps
un revenu n'a pas demandé de venir pour
vous dire qu'elle avait choisi de donner
son corps à la science en parle des
cartes rêver donner pour aider la
science pour aider les futurs médecins
bourne et les chercheurs auxquels elle
voulait vraiment faire un acte généreux
et quand on voit ce qu'ils ont créé
derrière moi ça me rend dingue ça me
rend malade
[Musique]
problème tout ce scandale qui vous a
sauté vos yeux en novembre c'est que
comme beaucoup de fair minsk à ma
famille à moi on pensait avoir fait le
deuil de la mort de ma mère et on se
rend compte que c'est pas le cas puisque
hormis tout remonte à la surface tout
autour sur lui avec toutes les images
terribles en passant la tête
évidemment il n'y a aucune raison
qu'elle soit passée à travers les
mailles du filet pour maman mais
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
réservé comme sort là tu en sais rien et
je saurai jamais parce qu'il y avait une
traçabilité en plus moi j'ai appelé des
quartiers demandé qu on restitue les
restes et dell ne savent pas ils savent
pas ils savent rien
[Musique]
on a été content de voir que ça avait
été publiée ça veut dire que quelque
chose avance on a été par contre très
déçu de voir qu'il y avait un extrait
est pas l'intégralité de cette enquête
on se demande pourquoi d'ailleurs la
ministre ne veut pas révéler le contenu
de cette enquête
ça me paraît important pour ce conte
on
voilà aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
chagrin bien sûr il ya un énorme
sentiment de trahison c'est à dire que
nos proches qui ont donné leurs corps
l'ont fait généreusement ils ont créé
éclaté dans des murs dans des voitures
pour des crash tests
ils ont fait les trafics de tête de mon
bon c'est pas trop à cesser les ont
laissés se faire manger par des rats ou
pourrir dans une chambre froide être 17
degrés j'ai extrêmement choquée hélas
oui je parle de trahison c'est une
trahison
on n'a pas respecté la volonté de nos
défunts alors nous notre combat il est
pour que les coupables dans toute cette
horreur soit retrouvée soient jugés
soient punis l'année se doit ce qu'on
voudrait aussi c'est qu'il ya un
encadrement beaucoup plus strict du don
des corps en france parce que là il ya
vraiment un flou artistique et chaque
centre de dons mais un petit peu comme
ils veulent que les donneurs puisse
choisir à quoi ils sont après il se
destine ainsi je veux dire
alors
oh
alors là l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on est un juge d'instruction qui soit
nommé pour pouvoir instruire des
plaintes et pouvant déboucher sur un
procès on sait pas exactement ce qui se
passe votre avocat non plus qu'on prend
pas dans des affaires un petit peu moins
grave quand même ça a été très vite pour
avoir un juge d'instruction
nous c'est quand même quelque chose rous
ampleur qui a duré longtemps alors
évidemment toutes les huiles ça c'est
sûr et donc on appelle juge
d'instruction
l'argent c'est quoi alors c'est quoi ces
deux affirmé d'abord une collaboration
l'établissement l enquête judiciaire
dans la dent de la manifestation de
vérité est question qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui s'est passé il ya des
responsabilités
jacques toute la lumière soit faite sur
les chevilles rapporté ville de paris
n'est pas là pour désigner des
responsables pour accélérer et
l'endurance
je pense que déjà si on a ça en
perspective on ira tous un petit peu
mieux on se dira qu s'allier à la
justice fait son travail et qu'on va
pouvoir être en paix quoi qu'il se passe
quel que soit le jugement on va
certainement être frustré des verdicts
qui vont tomber
mais au moins il y aurait eu justement
ça me permettra d'être apaisé et de
peut-être voilà laisser partir nos
proches faire un deuil
un vrai deuil et qu'on en reparle de
plus à quoi que ce soit terminé